I can confirm today that we are
accepting the headline recommendations
of the pay review bodies in full
but we will not fund them by borrowing
more or increasing your taxes
it would not be right to increase taxes
on everyone to pay some people more
particularly when household budgets are
so tight
neither would it be right to pay for
them by higher borrowing
because higher borrowing simply makes
inflation worse
instead because we only have a fixed pot
of money to spend from that means
government departments have had to find
savings and efficiencies elsewhere in
order to prioritize paying public sector
workers more
now there's a clear message here
there are always choices
budgets are not infinite when some ask
for higher pay
that will always create pressures
elsewhere costs which must ultimately be
borne by the taxpayer or by spending
Less on our other priorities
so that's our decision and having
honored the independent pay review
process I urge all union leaders to
accept these payoffers and call off
their strikes
already earlier this year the NHS staff
Council representing over half a dozen
unions and over a million NHS workers
made a significant decision and voted to
accept our payoffer and suspend strikes
I'm grateful to them and their members
and today
in response to the news of our decision
I'm pleased to say we've had another
major breakthrough
all teaching unions have just announced
that they're suspending all plan strikes
immediately
teachers will return to the classroom
disruption to our children's education
will end
and the unions have themselves confirmed
that this payoffer is properly funded
and so they're recommending to their
members an end to the entire dispute